rappelle que fin 2015 la france a réuni
195 pays
195 et là c'est pas 150 e chefs
d'entreprise ces 195 pays pour une coop
21 qui a débouché sur un accord avec
laurent fabius comme ordonnateur et
grand organisateur de cette comme 21
donc la france était présente sur la
scène internationale puisque ça veut
dire de montrer comme ça qu'ils auraient
une rupture totale et que d'un seul coup
la france serait de retour c'est très
politicien mais ça m'étonne pas
une aubaine tendant à faire beaucoup de
puces de communications que
d'objectivité
voilà c'est tout est ce qu'après je ne
suis pas là pour dire que c'est mal où
ces braves aussi enthousiaste non je
suis là pour rappeler des faits oui mais
j'aimerais bien que de temps en temps
vous de mon s'en souviennent
on vous appelle d'autres c'est ce que
vous avez bien sûr qu'il va intervenir
quelques peut-être comme une forme
d'hommage est ce que vous ne voyez pas
une fluence une sorte de parallèle entre
la com 21 fin 2015 est l'événement de ce
soir est ce que c'est pas au fond une
comme pts 21 de l'attractivité de la
france a lieu ce soir du tout ce qu'il
ya 150 chefs d'entreprise par rapport à
195 pays désolé de vous dire que la
comparaison est vite fait
s'il y avait un vrai mais ça c'est si
c'est pour la question de la france
ce que j'ai entendu c'est de dire que
cette réunion à versailles
je vous rappelle aussi que laurent
fabius avait organisé sur la question de
la gastronomie à versailles un grand
événement sur l'attractivité sur le fait
que malgré et après des attentats qui
nous ont touché le tourisme dès 2017 est
revenu à un niveau extrêmement élevé ça
faisait partie des stratégies d'ailleurs
qui avaient été fixés et par le
président de la république et par
laurent fabius
franchement soyons objectifs en ce
moment je vais vous faire cela il ya là
beaucoup de parti-pris n'a que riom
objectif regardons les choses telles
qu'elles sont alors on va tendre à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on se serait retrouvé
avec une france qui est de retour comme
si elle avait été absente avant et je
voudrais ici
jean-yves
le drian quand jean yves le drian s'il
l'a dit c'est une erreur alors voilà ce
que créateur il était ministre de la
défense
je me souviens que les premiers rafale
pour ne parler que de la question de
l'armement
on a vendu des rafales camp quand on
était aux affaires
et qu'on diriger la france alors c'est
votre ancien collègue effectivement vous
l'avez côtoyé au gouvernement et lui il
dit effectivement que le regard sur la
france a changé il le dit dans une
interview au figaro ce matin en ces
termes la france a aujourd'hui une force
et une capacité d' influence que nous
n'avons pas connu depuis longtemps
depuis longtemps dit il
c'est pas très sympa de sa part
l'aridité ressentez vous l'avais dit
c'était moi regarde un point
d'interrogation n'est pas très sympa non
c'est pas très sympa mais surtout c'est
pas très objectif qui va donner de
macron avec son élection
et d'ailleurs il en a fait un enjeu
politique sur cette scène internationale
soit présent c'est pas moi qui vais le
contester que cette présence eux à
l'échelle internationale détendent ou si
un contexte très particulier
angela merkel elle n'était pas du tout
dans la situation de la callas les
aujourd'hui quand nous sommes et quand
françois hollande est arrivé à la
présidence de la république le break
site affaibli la grande bretagne a qu'à
voir les débats d'aujourd'hui et puis
quand à donald trump
il isole politiquement et
diplomatiquement les états unis donc il
ya un contexte international qui donne
une visibilité emmanuel macron et à la
france un leader sûrement plaire et
versez pas m'en plaindre mais de dire à
partir de là que alors été absente avant
je fais simplement le constat je voulais
dit qu'ils avaient été plus que présente
puisqu'elle a été capable de faire en
sorte que les pays du monde viennent en
france
et si un accord exceptionnel sur la
question de lance des fans et